-I'm very impressed that
you use your time off
from your television job
to come do stage work.
-Uh-huh. I do.
-Last time you were here,
you were doing a one-man show,
"Fully Committed."
-Yes. Yes.
-Now, this time, you're
actually sharing the stage
with some other actors.
-There's a few other actors.
The last one, I played
40 characters in a one-man show,
and, this time,
I'm playing one character
in a play with six people.
-Okay. So that's --
-That's more -- That's --
I like that more.
-You like that more. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I can imagine
playing 40 characters
for however many nights you
did it was pretty exhausting.
-It was great.
I mean, I lost like 15 pounds
during the run.
If you want to lose weight,
just do a one-man show.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-It's really...
-That's what they all say.
-This is an interesting play
about the different
kind of people
that can start families...
-Right.
-..and how they start families.
-Yeah.
And it's sort of like
about the breakdown
of the, you know, empathy
between subcultures
of the LGBTQ community.
And I -- That sounds
really dry and boring,
but it's actually
a really funny play,
and there are a lot of moments
where, like,
"I can't believe you just said
that, but you did."
And you actually learn --
I'm learning a lot
about the transgender community.
And it's -- it's a really
great play, very timely.
-Well, that's helpful, because,
you know,
I do think there are things
we could all --
all want to learn
about different communities,
and sometimes
we are afraid that,
if we ask, we'll seem ignorant.
-Yeah, I had friends who came,
and, like, we ask some of these
questions in the play,
and my friends were like,
"Oh, we want to know
the answer to that, too."
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Like, truly --
like, "I've always been scared
to ask that question."
So it's -- it's great.
-You are introduced in the play
as a gay uncle who's
in charge of babysitting.
You do some babysitting.
-Yes.
I used to babys-- that
was like my bread and butter
before I became
a successful actor.
[ Light laughter ]
-Wow.
Were you good?
Were you --
-I was an amazing babysitter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You really were? Okay.
-I really was
a great babysitter.
I babysat for a friend of mine
who was an actor,
and I had just, you know,
his daughter Nora,
and I would take her to, like,
in the parks,
and I would meet other parents
while I was at the parks.
And they would kind of be like,
"Who's that guy?
Can -- Do you -- Do you have --
Do you do this a lot?
Do -- Do you have time, like,
on Thursday?
Can you come by?
Like, we're short a babysitter."
And so I started getting poached
by other parents.
-Wow.
-And then I started,
like, hedging them
against one another.
It's like, "Well,
Mrs. Morrison pays $12 an hour."
[ Laughter ]
So, like, you know --
I was really --
I was quite a shark.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That's very impressive.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
-And I'm also...
-And not to say
I won't go back to it
when "Modern Family" is done.
I mean...
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
If anyone wants me to...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But let's make it clear.
-Yeah, my rates have gone up.
-It's not 12 bucks anymore,
yeah.
-Let's talk about inflation.
Yeah.
-Do you like using your off time
from being
in front of a TV camera
to come back and do theater?
-I do. I love it.
I mean, with --
when you're on camera --
and you know this
from doing TV --
like, you -- your --
your performance is edited
in another room.
And, like, in theater, you know,
you're in complete charge --
in control of your --
your performance.
I think it's so exciting.
-And it's great.
And you can adjust based on
the audience on any given night.
-Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
Like, you're not laughing
right now,
so, then, I would do, like,
something wacky like this,
and then you'd start laughing.
[ Laughter ]
So, you know,
you can do things like that.
-You got them.
-And you can wave to Fred
when you're feeling insecure.
[ Laughter ]
And he doesn't wave back,
but that's fine.
That's fine. It's fine.
It's like, don't worry about it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Fred.
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Applause ]
-You -- You and your husband
just traveled.
-Yeah.
-You went to London.
You went to Paris.
-And Berlin.
-Berlin.
-Which I'd never been to before.
-How is Berlin?
-It's great.
It's great for people
who are willing
to, like, see the sunrise.
-Yeah.
-Which --
I'm not one of those people.
I really like sleep.
[ Laughter ]
-I went to Berlin once, and
I think I went a little late.
Like, my party days were over,
and I felt like an old man.
-Oh, yeah. Mine, too.
Absolutely, I'm with you.
We should go to Berlin together.
-Yeah. Great.
-But I -- We --
-Did you make an effort?
-We did make an effort.
One night, we definitely made it
to like 8:00 a.m.
Yeah.
-That's great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And...
we were really proud
of ourselves,
and then, we basically fell
asleep for a whole day
and lost a day in Berlin.
-Yeah.
-That's not great.
-So it wasn't fully worth it,
to be honest.
-You did not go to the Tonys.
-No.
No, I was doing --
I was onstage that night.
-Right, so, but you did go
to Tonys after parties.
-I went to the after parties,
which I think is probably
the way to do it now.
-Yeah.
-Just, like, skip the ceremony,
and go to the parties.
And, again, I was kind of trying
to relive my Berlin days.
I was, like,
staying out way too late.
-Oh, no.
-Yeah, it was --
-But you just found out
from Berlin
that you're not cut for that.
-Mm-hmm.
-How did you forget so quickly?
-I just forgot very quickly.
Enough liquor
makes you forget things.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I knew it was time to leave
when my friend Colin
brought me back --
I had been drinking vodka sodas,
and he brought me back
a drink that --
it was a tequila and water
with no ice in a Martini glass,
and he's like,
"This is all they have left."
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Then we need to go home."
-Yeah.
-Like, that's when you leave.
-Right.
-"We can't be here anymore."
-Yeah, you can stay --
you can keep drinking your first
choice and your second choice.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But when
it's the last choice...
-And it's warm...
-Yeah.
-...and in a Martini glass,
and it doesn't belong in that,
it's just --
it's time to go home.
-Yeah.
-It's like, "I can give you
a pint of rosé..." Unh-unh.
-Yeah, in, like, a sippy cup.
You're like,
"I don't feel like this is what
I should be doing right now."
-I didn't realize this --
which is an incredible pull --
Tony Kushner, the incredible
playwright, married you guys.
-Yeah.
Yeah, he was our officiant.
Yeah, he wrote
"Angels in America"
and is a Pulitzer Prize winner
for that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And...yeah.
-And, of course...
he -- you know, he deservedly --
that show won a Tony this year.
-Yeah, they won tons of Tonys.
-Have you seen the revival?
-I have seen it.
I loved it.
I was highly impressed with it.
Nathan Lane, of course,
is in it.
And he's -- he plays Pepper
on "Modern Family."
So I was there to see him,
and it's so amazing seeing him
in a role
that's completely different
from the role he plays on
"Modern Family."
-Did you see it same day,
back to back?
-I did two days.
I needed --
I had to sleep in between.
-Got you.
-Some people do this
throughout one day,
and I was like, I feel --
I feel better going to bed
between plays.
-Yeah, but you did do them
back-to-back days?
You did have a --
-Yes. Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely, yeah.
-That's really cool.
But, I mean, it was --
it was fantastic.
It's an amazing production
that people should
definitely try and catch.
-It's amazing that
you pulled Tony Kushner
as an officiant
for your wedding.
-I just asked him,
and he said, "Yes,"
which is --
I mean, I kind of knew him,
but not well enough to say,
"Will you marry us?"
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"Well, I'm gonna just try."
And he said, "Okay."
And, like, we basically had,
like, a breakfast together
where he, like,
asked us how we met.
I'm like,
"This is just so weird."
[ Laughter ]
"You're gonna marry us."
I'm just like, "Well,
this is our origin story."
[ Laughter ]
And...
But he wrote this ceremony
that I was like,
"Well, you're gonna win
a second Pulitzer for this
because it's amazing."
[ Laughter ]
-That's fantastic.
-So beautiful. Yeah.
-Well, that --
He still hasn't given me
the transcript of the ceremony
yet, though.
-Oh, interesting.
-So, if he's watching...
I'm sure he watches every night.
-I'm sure he is, yes.
-...I need that.
-Okay, great.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks so much for being here.
-Absolutely.
-It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Jesse Tyler Ferguson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]